hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
round 10 of our coverage the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament got an exciting game
today White's gonna be played by Peter
Svidler he's been in the middle of pack
for most of the tournament his opponent
Shakira we looked at one of his matches
earlier on he's been playing extremely
extremely well he's been near the top of
the leaderboard for most of the
tournament coming into this round he is
a point back of an HDTV after an issue
replayed he drew today so Shakira is a
point behind if he could get a victory
he would now be tied for first with an
injury and Magnus crossed him for a
three-way tie so we're going to get into
it Peter Svidler starts out with pawn to
c4 we see Knight f6 Knight f3 pawn e6
Knight c3 and this is getting into the
Queen's Gambit line and we do see the
Queen's game it decline after the bishop
comes down here to b4 we see pons takes
to d5 now after the pottery captures
Bishop here to F force and this is a
variation we don't see very often this
allows black to be very aggressive by
bringing the knight down here to e4
attacking this night the night can't
take here on e4 because this Knights
being pinned down by the bishop to the
King here on a1 you can also see it is
somewhat difficult for white to kick off
this bishop right here unless he wants
to be left with not the best pawn chain
ever or even down material you can see
the pawn right now is the only piece
that is defending this night here on c3
so we see Peters pillar decides to go
ahead and bring his Queen out Queen to
a4 check really the only option for
black tend to fitness is Knight to c6
and then rook to c1 there's kind of two
options if you wanted to fin this night
since the pond the only option right now
you could see Queen to b3 that's one
option or rook over here to see one
decides to not for the rook to see one
and then castle on the King side Shakir
doesn't really have to worry about doing
anything else he's still pinning
down the night to the king it's gonna
take a few moves for Peter Svidler to
get his King out of safety
he could play pawn to e3 try to get his
Bishop maybe to just e to castle on the
Kings side could play pawn to g3 Fink
head over to the King side and then
castle on the Kings side but right now
it's gonna be a few move so no hurry
right now he's putting a ton of pressure
on his opponents so for now Chuck you're
just gonna hang out here with this setup
bishop here on b4 and knight on e4 the
last option in Peters fiddler has is to
not worry about his King right now being
pinned down instead attack his
opponent's Bishop with the move pawn to
a3 this is what I favor the most I just
feel like black is putting so much
pressure this forces their hand they're
not gonna be able to continue this
pressure if they come back here to a5
you just swing your pawn up here to b4
there is going to be an exchange right
here Bishop you could just see the pawn
recapture here the Knights not gonna
retake I think White's gonna be ok in
this position still gonna have to worry
about that's not on e4 which is pretty
annoying but I do think this is better
than just allowing your opponent to
continue to put pressure on you Peters
fiddler disagrees with me he plays pawn
to g3 deciding to fee and Kidd on the
Kings side to try to get some protection
for his King if he castles on the King
side this is where things get
interesting to me pawn to g5 says our
it's go time I am all-in on attack mode
I have a very strong position I don't
want to let up at all I won't attack as
fast as possible now usually with these
type of moves you'll see your opponent
spend quite a bit of time trying to
figure out the best variation Peters
fiddler took 3 seconds and he played
Bishop X here at e3 so he seemed pretty
familiar with this situation and then
pawn to f5 and this is where you start
to see ok black is literally going
all-in on an attack there is no more
passive play trying to keep material in
front of the King it is all in from here
then we see the bishop to
jeetu and then pawn to f4 from black and
this is the first move we're either side
took time on board
mosa both sides were taking anywhere
from three to ten seconds some of them
up to 30 seconds but they were very very
quick this took a shake here 30 minutes
to think about and we see 34 minutes
from Peters fuller trying to figure out
the best variation to go from here
and he decided to go ahead and take with
his pont pawn takes here on g4 now we
see the bishop take on c3 the pond
recapture the pond take and now the
bishop comes back here to d2 as you can
see this is porting a lot of pressure on
white starting to have a cramp position
all this pieces not gonna be able to get
involved too much and black really has a
strong attack first decide to play King
to h8 this allows the rook to swing over
here to g8 put a lot of pressure on his
opponent you can also see from White's
perspective doesn't even look that good
to Castle anymore you're just putting it
on the G file where your opponent's
gonna tax it that doesn't look that good
but now you're just gonna have a king in
the center of the board
there's just eying down this night here
on e4 putting a lot of pressure what
Chuck here's also doing a really good
job of its taking this Queen out of the
game as soon as this Queen came over to
a4 he's been locked out and it's very
difficult for this Queen to actually get
involved into the game now the next move
from Peters fiddler he wanted to try to
get his Queen involved into the game he
played Queen to b3 but this doesn't do
too much and you know from here how does
white really get his Queen involved he
could have tried other moves rook to g1
is an option so knowing that his
opponent's gonna come to g8 and start to
attack maybe he tries that you can see
Bishop here to g4 Knights up here to e5
maybe the knight comes takes material
here on f2 the King's not able to take
after King takes on f2 then the Queen
comes down h4 check things get extremely
bad King f1 Knight takes on e5
on takes we could see check King takes
on e2 with the discovered attack pawn to
f3 check and after the king or the
bishop takes then you could see the
Queen come over here take here on a4 so
while the King's not able to take this
maybe we see the knight come back here
to g4 and the knight takes up here this
is just further weakening everything in
front of the King but I feel like white
does have some options maybe now cleanup
here to b5 this does allow it to come
back to d3 if it wants to get more
involved into the game maybe Knight
takes on h2 King to d1 not a great
position for white but does have some
options if you didn't want to try Queen
to b3 we see black now play Knight to a5
which forces the Queen to move Queen to
c2 and now Knight to c4 another square
very very difficult for white to deal
with though this is a great outpost this
pawn on d5 is doing so much work
controlling both of the c4 and E for
square for the Knights and there's just
not a lot of squares that white really
has to go on board now we see white play
rook to d1 really just in full defense
mode right now
rook to g8 as we talked about and then
might appear to be 5 just trying to get
some material involved into the game the
knight takes the bishop takes here on e4
and then Queen down to g5 and this is
such a tricky spot as well because it's
very difficult for whites to do what he
wants to and that would be to take one
of these pieces in the middle
if the bishop takes well then the Queen
just comes down here to g1 check force
to take and then it's going to be
checkmate same thing if the pawn takes
the knight here Queen's gonna come down
to G 1 after the rook takes then the
rook to come down here checkmate so you
can see how important it is to have an
escape square for the King here on e1
couple options you could see Bishop
taking here on
F for so that would be one option or you
can see rook over here to F 1 we see
Pitters feller deciding to go with the
Bishop to f4 pretty much giving up
material knowing that he has to have
some room for his King to breathe we see
the Queen take here on f4 Bishop to d5
attacking the rook Black's not worried
about that at all Bishop down here to f5
attacking the Queen in this position
after only 21 moves we see Peter Svidler
resign I just did not see any way out of
this just too many threats to deal with
so theof the game congratulations -
Shakir he's now tied for first place
three weights high so really great game
from him playing the black pieces and
just came out just all in for the win
recognizing that with only a few more
matches left in this tournament getting
drawls even as the black pieces may not
be enough so went for it went for the
victory and got the victory in a short
amount of time so congratulations to him
hope you guys enjoyed round 10 of the
Tata Steel tournament it's been a good
one so far thank you for the support and
I'll see you guys in the next video